we were on the ground in Pickens South
Carolina for Donald Trump's Fourth of
July weekend rally our correspondent
Luke Beasley was there now if you've
been following the show for a while you
know that Luke's done some wild
interviews
I believe they all pale in comparison to
what Luke saw there this weekend and
Luke's done a great job but the level of
nuttiness and cultishness that we saw
there this weekend is something to
behold this is likely the best and worst
one ever now remember you can find
Luke's YouTube channel at
davidpackman.com Luke Luke and I
strategize before this event and I said
it might be useful it might be
interesting
to focus in specifically on the
indictment and the audio tape of trump
admitting to crimes
I was shocked myself at how insane the
answers from these folks were let's
start with this first guy completely
confused
understands nothing cannot think quite
frankly shocking he can even get dressed
in the morning listen to this what are
your thoughts on the Federal indictment
my thoughts oh I'm not worried about it
not worried like you don't think he did
what he's being accused of
it's like you know they hand out
diamonds like cookies yeah oh he's only
been died twice
I mean
like so you have the Manhattan D.A and
then the federal oh that Manhattan D.A
what a piece I mean a porn star I mean
it looked
every rich person had sex with a porn
star yep already Family Values though
right already a family values right I
mean I've had sex with a porn star
oh God here we go
really really you know
I'm not gonna comment on that
okay you judge for yourselves
whether this young man
had sex with a porn star all right
and you would be a good candidate in the
party of family values you know what we
all make mistakes it's so show me a man
with no convention conviction of the
past you know show me a man who I mean I
I have no convictions in my past just
never said a cuss word show me a man
that's never you know had perverted
thoughts show me a man preferred her
thoughts about their own daughter like
Trump
foreign
I think I was a joke he said that on The
View they'll defend anything anything
he'll defend and uh that was on The View
and he said he would like to he said if
he was dating somebody he would date a
woman like his dog the most reading
recent reporting says that they're
defending Trump fantasizing about his
own daughter
folks the white house he has been
overheard fantasizing about having sex
with her how does that relate what's
going on right now I just think it's
gross
but but she asked me what do I think
about his indictment why oh I know he's
probably a porn star so here we are look
I mean look we've all looked at porn
we've all there you go oh you know we're
just really going
so what this is the first clip I saw
from what Luke sent me
and I said oh my goodness if this is
what this is going to be like this is
going to be crazy it actually gets even
more nuts here is a guy Luke explains
what about ISM to this guy
and the guy doesn't get it and just
responds with more what about ISM I mean
there's an inability to be able to think
here arguments oh what about ism
no what is it uh it's a logical fallacy
when you try to respond to someone's
argument kind of break down someone's
argument by just referencing something
else separate from the conversation you
guys do that all the time I have no you
can't talk to also what about is it
right there I know the point is you
can't talk to a liberal you're talking
to one right now
I could wrap you around my finger in two
seconds the bottom line is careful I
don't know what that means okay what it
means is you've been lying so long you
don't know how to tell the truth
what it also means is you've stayed
really quite aligned that applies to
Trump right you've been lying so long
you don't know how to tell the truth
each the entire Insanity for so long you
still don't know how to tell the truth
so we're unraveling it it's like a piece
of thread on the sweater so do you agree
hard and you guys are losers do you
agree the Espionage Act outlines certain
things you can and can't do with
classified materials yeah so why do you
agree on an audio don't you agree same
thing for bug because we don't have
evidence that he did the same things
Trump did not only did he do it he had
no authority to do it as vice president
he obstructed investigation classify
anything he wanted as president but this
piece of direct can't do anything as
vice president do you understand let's
bring the heat down and just let me ask
an honest question in the recording
that's been released now you can hear
Trump saying this is still classified I
could have Declassified as president but
I didn't know okay he didn't know no no
he didn't know he did know it doesn't
matter here he didn't know or it doesn't
matter but why is isn't Biden in prison
by now he talked to the FBI months
earlier I said give us the documents
give us a document help you not a
problem you guys are creating a mountain
out of a mobile because you don't want
them to run that's how stupid you are
you're afraid that all this is going to
materialize on a much bigger scale and
he gets elected that's why you guys
can't handle it
this guy is really a piece of work and
when Luke confronts the exact same guy
with facts about what Trump did the
substance of the indictment the guy says
grow up
and mentions China I'm not kidding this
is these folks vote so we've got to make
sure we're voting and the people that
are in charge are so evil and so
disgusting and so fascist all of us are
vulnerable including you
if they don't like you just look at what
they're doing to Trump just realize that
but like I would never hold on to
classified documents and then lie to
Federal authorities and interrupting
investigation and then conspire with
staffers to hide the contents
right grow up please okay that's our
priority look what's going on around the
world
China Russia you're worried about
documents yeah more what about ISM there
as you can see the next guy confidently
says the indictment is garbage but he
hasn't read it and says the audio
recording is garbage but he didn't
listen to it and then when he gets
pinned up against the wall with facts he
says doesn't everybody do the same thing
that Trump did uh what are your thoughts
about the Trump indictment
uh it's probably garbage probably
garbage did you read it no okay and then
what about the audio recording that got
released probably garbage you didn't
listen to it
how would you know it's garbage if you
don't even look into it some serious
things are being uh accused here
like tell me what it is mishandling and
uh classify documents holding on to them
when he wasn't supposed to have them all
right uh violating a subpoena lying to
Federal authorities obstructing
investigations and conspiring with other
staffers to move around documents to
keep federal authorities from getting
them it's like stealing a candy bar guys
come on
sounds uh sounds pretty serious but
doesn't everybody do that
this would be a comedy if it wasn't so
serious and so tragic and so sad doesn't
everybody do all that exact same stuff
all right then we go and we hear from a
woman
who is suspicious of the audio recording
of trump admitting to crimes she's
suspicious that it even it really exists
she's like there is no audio tape that's
weird and then another woman pops up and
they both seem really confused and
you'll notice they don't know anything
they use words whose meaning they don't
understand they are their mouths are
moving I hear noise I recognize the
words they don't know the meaning of
these words listen to this well it's
like why do they have an auto recording
I mean that's like going back to
Superman with uh you know the olseness
the reporter carrying a little recorder
why didn't they have video they could
have had him on video but they didn't
you know it's just it's plus he has the
presidential he has with no discretion
he has no discretion she doesn't even
know what she's saying ever he can take
his
you know that the record side the
presidential yeah and protect but is he
has been charged with the Espionage Act
Right or violating it no he he in terms
of everything he had them
they had the opportunity to go through
everything right and they told him just
to put some better locks on and they
came back you know
um there you go he has the right as a
president to certify and do or
declassify this is Obama's uh fourth run
there you go but Obama's running for the
fourth time right now Obama
this is fourth presidency he's
controlling stuff yeah absolutely the
only thing Obama hasn't checked off of
his list yet is um freedom of speech he
wants that gone and he's campaigning
everywhere on every platform that he can
get on and that's one of the main things
weaponize the FBI weaponized so what's
interesting is some of the vocabulary of
the conspiracy theories has trickled
down into their brains they just don't
really understand it or know how to use
it Harris
and freedom of speech and guns all of
that he want those are on his little
checklist and that's what he's doing yep
it's actually it's quite fitting that
this interview is being done in front of
a row of about a dozen porta-potties
because everything coming out of the the
mouths of these people really deserves
to be flushed 10 to 15 times
um then uh speaks to two more women who
say the tape doesn't exist and
um it must be AI it must be actually
it's not really Trump if there is a tape
it's AI
um okay and then one of the big things
in the news right now is that tape of
trump caught on recording no that that
has been debunked that there it doesn't
exist have you not heard that
that tape does not exist I heard it it
doesn't fake like AI Trump voice it must
be because they tried to produce it and
they couldn't produce it because it does
not exist even though I listened to it
it might have been AI I don't know but
they tried to produce the actual tape
there is a I think there's there's film
but there's no sound there you go in
fact there is there is no video that I'm
aware of
uh when Trump got asked about it he just
said no no in the recording I
he didn't deny that he said all the
things in the recording why wouldn't he
say oh that was fake if it was fake I'm
not in his head
that's a good question even Trump's not
denying the authenticity of the
recording he's just saying he wasn't
really showing anybody papers I don't
know I don't know what Trump's thinking
um fascinating stuff then we go to a guy
this guy is probably racist is my sense
this guy refers to Luca's boy he said
hey boy
let's listen what that man is talking is
the only person
alive on this Earth that can save this
Republic peacefully
peacefully
now if he's not elected
you listen to this boy this
folks this is not not an actor
Central Casting right that's Trump like
says this is not an actor as far as we
know Republic shall survive
regardless of what the hell it takes
okay poke that over in your pipe
I'm smoking it okay the guy says to Luke
smoke that in your pipe he says in
calling Luke boy
he says uh Trump's the only guy who can
peacefully save us but if he loses then
all bets are off and it's very much not
going to be peaceful and the last guy
Luke spoke to this stuff needs to be in
the National Archives really
um Luke speaks to a guy with no shirt on
who it hasn't read the indictment hasn't
heard the audio but he has really strong
feelings about both do you think
lokeness I hear a lot about wokeness on
the right is that a big problem
uh like being woke like these woke
companies yeah yeah for sure how would
you define awoke woke like leave the
damn kids alone that's for sure that
pisses me off right woke is leave the
dick is a plan dude I didn't want to get
into this too deep and stuff like that
because I do got to carry on but
basically just being woke like you're
just shoving crap down our throats like
you have to do this and you have to do
that and you have to obey this and you
can't say that because Sally over there
is going to get offended and you can't
read this book you can't be gay Etc yeah
dude all sorts of things and it's
annoying I'm sick of it I just want
people to be happy there you go and then
then they actually get to the part about
the indictment here here's that so with
the indictment have you read it and have
you heard the audio recording that's
been a big thing in the news not too
much in depth about it so it's a little
strange to me
since it's like such a big thing against
him and he's saying that Biden's
weaponizing the government against them
you know so then I want to be good to
know if that's happening or not no yeah
I mean like it totally it totally is
it's just like with Trump having to go
to court on multiple different occasions
for like all the stuff that the uh the
buttons are doing you know what I mean
with Hunter and Joe and all these trades
and this secret crap that's going on you
know and and then it's just like it's
kind of like hey look over here look at
look at Donald Trump you know like we're
arresting him and we're doing this and
that while they're doing all that
crooked stuff someone are do you agree
that right now they don't have hard
evidence otherwise they would be
broadcasting it on Fox News James Comer
admits we don't have the evidence right
now but we think we have the evidence
yeah I mean it's totally there so then
wouldn't it be like oh wait you think
that was there yeah I mean I think that
this stuff is there it's one of those
things that like I feel like they gotta
like put it out uh in a certain way like
a strategic they've got all the evidence
against Biden they're just waiting three
years to put it out kind of white you
can't just like blast it out there
because maybe stuff gets uh like spoiled
or some sort you know it's just let me
put it this way it's like if you leave
if you if you leave Mayo out too long it
spoils same thing with the evidence
against Biden you agree that I right now
can't see the evidence that's being
referred to I can't listen to the
recordings that are being like yeah no I
understand in that sense some people
would think maybe Trump we can read the
evidence in the indictment what they're
uh alleging and then hear the audio
which is one of the pieces of evidence
ourselves we can listen to it
we can't do the same with the buying
stuff so maybe the buying stuff is
actually Republican trying to distract
from the Trump stuff no yeah honestly
dude I feel like at this point we just
don't know until it actually happened so
with the indictment until what right
there may not be an indictment that
happened that's the whole point because
it doesn't appear as though they have
any evidence against Joe Biden
um incredible work by Luke this is what
we're up against and we have to support
Independent Media so remember you can go
over to Luke's Channel davidpackman.com
Luke and subscribe please make sure that
you're subscribed here last month in in
June a record three and a half million
people watched our videos but didn't
subscribe it's free to subscribe on
YouTube support the work we and others
are doing it is so important make sure
that you do that think of your most
personal emails if you're using a free
email provider you should know that
they're scanning every email you send
and receive even after you delete it
they're usually using the data to build
a picture of your life to show you ads
which many find creepy our sponsor start
mail never scans or tracks your emails
privacy is what comes first and unlike
other email Services when you delete an
email in start mail it is gone forever
it also protects your data by blocking
tracking pixels and emails which
companies and hackers can use to track
you you can create unlimited email
aliases to protect your identity and cut
down on spam you can encrypt every email
you send even if the recipient isn't
using encryption start mail gives you 20
gigs of storage that's more than you get
on Gmail and it only takes a few clicks
to migrate all of your emails and
contacts over to start mail go to
startmail.com Pacman to get 50 off your
first year that's only about two bucks a
month the link is down below so